Santa's secret is Santa here Santa are
you here Santa's here somewhere let's
see if we can find Santa Paws hey Conan
how's it going okay is there anything
you'd like to share with us Santa Claus
hmm nope see you later
come on san I'm sure there's some
secrets that you want to get off your
chest yeah well actually there is one
thing it's kind of embarrassing
Christmas is fun but the other 364 days
of the year I drive for uber oh and we
still make some toys at the North Pole
but these days we mostly manufacture
weapons for extremist groups some pretty
disturbing revelations from Santa yeah
oh one more thing I got rid of the
naughty and nice list now it's just fat
and not Falcon standard also until 1968
I had a separate lap for black kids
that's awful no one needed to know that
oh also Rudolph's nose doesn't just
light up it also vibrates real talent
that one okay you know what said that
more than anyone wants to know that's
fine oh oh one more thing
I did kiss your mommy but I was thinking
about you daddy okay
sano we got it well yeah and I don't
always eat the cookies you leave out for
me but I promise they don't make their
way inside me one way or another do you
want Conan you want to know how they get
inside me I'll give you six guests okay
I don't want to know nobody wants to
know I put your cookies in my butt
you
you